[Music]
a
let's talk about our democra for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
him what's the biggest load of horeshit
you have ever heard in your entire
life and I bet that biggest load of
horeshit does not compare to the biggest
[__] lie that I have ever heard in
politics ever
ever I have to stand in awe in awe of
this lie the biggest lie I've ever heard
and it is in Liz Cheney's new book which
is not surprising I told you this
[__] that
Trump was not eating are you [__]
kidding me you want us to
believe you want us to believe that
Trump wasn't eating now I don't know if
Kevin McCarthy actually said this [__]
to Liz Cheney I highly doubt it I
actually think Liz Cheney is a
[__] oh my God she is a world class
[__] liar her last name's Cheney what
do you want from me she's a [__]
Cheney she's just like her goddamn dad
she's Darth Vader Jr for crying out loud
and you want me to believe anything that
Liz Cheney says get the [__] out of here
with that [__] that Lon sack of
[__] I I I I keep telling you these
things I keep telling you that Liz
Cheney is not our friend Liz Cheney is
no friend of democracy she's no friend
of liberalism she's no friend to women's
rights she's no friend to women's
privacy in their doctor's office she's
no friend to Democrats she's no friend
to the lgbtq community she's no friend
to Liberty it's just not a thing I mean
you can go on and on and on about how
she's a hero cuz she did the bare
minimum and eventually said the truth
out loud like Ken Buck is now every oh
man Ken Buck he's such a great guy what
the [__] are you talking about it's
20203 and now all of a
sudden he's [__] going out on the
news and saying how oh yeah the truth is
the truth is the truth and if you lie
you're unamerican well [__] we've been
saying that since December of 2020 you
[__] [__] out of here with this
nonsense because Ken buck doesn't have
to run a campaign anymore and he doesn't
have to gather up a bunch of [__]
fascist votes now he's a hero get the
[__] out of here give me a [__] break
and Liz chany some kind of hero because
she wrote a book and she's trying to
profit off of Lies listen Trump has
never been hungry a day in his [__]
life and the [__] Maniac has never
been depressed do you think someone with
an an ego like that has ever been
depressed in their [__] life you're
out of your [__] mind you need to get
your goddamn head
checked if you think Trump was down at
maraco depressed and hungry give me a
[__] break the guy has Big Mac
buffets and he's bellied up to it
probably half the [__] day in the
other half he's doing his makeup and
putting the Trump drag on get the [__]
out of here with this
nonsense he was
hungry he wasn't
eating
oh oh goddamn oh goddamn that's some
funny [__] that's some funny [__]
[__] now the big headline today is that
the Republicans really jumped on a rake
with this Hunter Biden stuff but I
couldn't avoid the biggest lie in
politics that I've ever heard that's the
one I mean we all we all say the big lie
is that Trump that Trump won right
that's the big lie he spun the big lie
that's not actually the big lie I've
always thought the big lie was that he
had massive support in this country cuz
he doesn't he gets [__] booed off
football fields in South Carolina for
crying out loud and you want me to
believe that he's somehow popular get
the [__] out of
here you want me to believe the media's
polls so that they can [__] pimp fear
for profit get the [__] out of here with
that
nonsense I don't need that [__] in my
[__] life those lies in my life
and if you're standing around believing
these
lies I feel sorry for
you just like just like the lie that
Republicans Wanted Hunter Biden to come
testify now they don't want him
to and the reason why Comer's saying it
out loud because the Democrats will make
fools out of the
Republicans with the
truth CU that's that's really what's
going on here folks Republicans never
actually wanted hunter Biden to testify
they never wanted to actually depose him
it was GNA get the same result that
their Devin Archer deposition gave you
remember this they deposed Devon Archer
for hours in
private and Devon Archer said the exact
opposite of what their narrative is the
exact opposite under oath they didn't
even want to release the transcript of
Devon Archer it was so scathing against
their
narrative he specifically said Joe Biden
had nothing to do with business deals
nothing not a goddamn
thing and then this
morning this morning they're claiming on
Fox news that somehow there's $50
million that the Biden family got listen
folks listen to me clearly they keep
saying family because it's not the
president of the United States
and the $200,000 check that they got
they've already admitted that Joe Biden
didn't get any interest on that
loan it was 200 Grand that he gave his
brother and his brother paid him back no
interest it was a no interest loan to
his
brother you ever loaned your family
money you probably shouldn't it's not a
good idea not a good idea to loan your
family money if you're just going to do
it just give it to them that's my
suggestion and it's my personal belief
here right shouldn't really loan your
family money if they pay you back they
pay you back but you should never give
money expecting to get it back from a
family member just a personal opinion
right I come from the Midwest this kind
of [__]
happens but it's already been proven and
they've said it out
loud that there was no interest paid on
that loan because it was a loan to his
brother Jo B isn't a
bank they've admitted they've admitted
that they can't find anything wrong with
his tax returns and that's what's
suspicious oh all the tax returns that
Joe Biden has ever submitted to public
which is ever Joe Biden has submitted
like four [__] Decades of tax returns
folks four [__]
Decades of tax
returns when he was a Senator when he
was vice president president and now is
he's president and even during the time
when he wasn't in office which was only
four [__]
years he released those tax
returns and they're like oh there's
nothing suspicious about this that's
what makes it
suspicious I can't wait for Hunter Biden
to get into
public I can't [__] wait
actually frankly I can't wait for Hunter
Biden to sit in a [__] in a rake
Committee hearing the [__] committees
and self-identify his penis that is
bound to happen you you [__] don't
think that could happen that could
certainly happen I mean the Republicans
are obsessed with Hunter Biden dickpics
I mean they are obsessed with it so much
so that they're willing to enter it into
evidence
Marjorie Taylor green showing up showing
porn piics of Hunter Biden you don't
think it's possible [__] yes it's
possible hell yeah bring it on let's
[__] have that [__] kind of drama
let's do the trumpster fire if we're
going to do it let's do it the whole way
and let me tell you
something if if people don't think that
Hunter
Biden is smart you're you're a [__]
idiot I I mean I mean the guy does drugs
the guy likes hookers he's he's been
through some crazy [__] right there's no
doubt about
that and I definitely wouldn't vote for
him for probably any office I mean
unless he was running against a
republican then I would probably
consider it but I'm not voting for
Hunter Biden I didn't vote for Hunter
Biden Hunter Biden does not work in our
government he does not advise the
president of the United
States Hunter Biden is a successful
legal
consultant all around the world and yes
part of that is because his last name is
Biden that is the truth because that's
the American [__] way folks nepotism
nepotism nepotism how do you think
people get into big colleges how do you
think these [__] boneheads out there
that have [__] law degrees get to
these [__] these schools and get
these [__] law degrees these people
aren't [__]
smart it does does not take anything to
be a lawyer in this country hell it
probably doesn't take much to be a
[__] doctor if you want to know the
goddamn truth and that's the scary part
about it
all is the elite class in this country
wants to look down on normal average
working Americans like we're some kind
of [__]
scum that we're some kind of [__]
scum that they're better than us because
they were born into this family or they
went to this school are their [__]
families
Rich hell half the [__] Republicans
out there are goddamn elitist Ted Cruz
went to Ivy League Josh Holly went to
[__] ivy
league and they look down on and they
look down on
us and they want to Yammer on about the
elites the elites the elites Jesus
Christ Donald Trump the last [__] two
months has been standing in front of a
New York courtroom bragging bragging
about his mans
in South Florida how it's worth a
billion and a half
dollars and you don't think he's a
[__]
Elite he went to the warden School of
Business his daddy was rich [__] he said
at one point the the only way to be
successful and go to college is to take
a million dollar loan from your [__]
your
daddy the [__] out of here with this n
sense of course Hunter Biden is an elite
his dad was a United States senator for
years his [__] brother was the
Attorney General of
Delaware they should worship Hunter
Biden if you want to know the truth they
should worship
him they they should love Hunter Biden
more than they love
Trump that's right
I mean that's the reason why they love
Trump is the reason why they hate Hunter
Biden right think about
it his his daddy is an elite
right the only reason why Hunter Biden
is who he is is because of his
dad Hunter Biden loves the spotlight
right yeah loves the spotlight M he
loves to GR stand that's what they're
saying right now on the
news as they're talking about why Hunter
Biden wants to testify publicly is
because he wants to grandstand he loves
the
spotlight sounds like someone else I
know he loves women he loves [__]
hookers he loves [__] he loves porn
stars he loves he loves to have
sex
H Sou s like someone else I
know loves drugs loves
blow loves to go to foreign
countries and get pissed on H well that
might be someone else that might that
might actually be someone else I don't
know the hunter Buton actually likes
golden showers or not I don't know if he
has that in common with Grandpa poopy
pants they should worship Hunter Biden
and he buys guns illegally
oh my God he breaks federal gun laws oh
my God he should be their [__] they
they should fan girl him all day
long I mean tell me I'm wrong try to
tell me I'm [__]
wrong goddamn Hunter Biden should be
their [__] rockar they love Ted Nan
they love Kid Rock they love Donald
Trump
they love margerie Taylor
green Lauren bber who goes to [__]
Beetle Juice and gives hand jobs
marjerie Taylor green who cheats on her
husband with a sex
guru give me a [__] break they love
Madison
cawthorne remember Madison
cawthorne the cocaine sex orgies guy
yeah they loved him
too they love Hunter Biden
Hunter Biden is their Idol if you want
to know the God's honest
truth problem is there's he's Trump's
opponent because they can't pin this
stuff on Uncle Joe they can't pin this
stuff on Joe
Biden I don't know if Joe Biden's ever
had sex with a hooker I have no idea
honestly I don't think it [__]
matters I don't know that Joe Biden's
ever done drugs I have no idea I don't
think it [__] matters honestly I
would probably respect Joe a little more
if he would do some drugs honestly who
isn't doing drugs these days for crying
out loud [__] if you're not doing drugs
you're not doing life right if if you
want to know the honest
truth you gotta drink Jagger and and and
and eat gummies that's my life motto
[__]
it but they should love Hunter Biden and
they should love this
testimony but they
don't they because they know what it
means if Hunter Biden comes and
testifies in
public he's not going to appear to be
the hunter Biden that they portrayed him
to
be he just
won't and I think I think the way that
the attorney has written this letter to
challenge James cob and the oversight
committee um because they really are
painting Hunter Biden as the President
of the United States which is [__]
ridiculous and you know what we we kept
letting them throw this rake out for
themselves time and time again and I'm
happy about it and and I you know
honestly we should make this the biggest
rake that they could step on and it's
becoming that
way but the cult is believing them I
don't know if you noticed that I mean
really honestly you would think like wow
the cult should really be pissed off
about
this because the cult should think oh
yes we should get him in public public
is the best way to do this but they're
on Fox News they're on oan they're on
Newsmax anywhere they can go and be like
no no no no the best way is a private
deposition and the reason why is because
we want to ask him hundreds of
questions that have to do with
transactions my guess is is that there's
going to be two ways
of this Hunter Biden is going to give
private deposition and he's going to
give public
testimony and my guess is that Hunter
bid's going to make fools of these
idiots in both of these things and the
reason why is because Hunter Biden has
probably had to sit down with his
lawyers God knows how much money he's
had to pay them to go line by line by
line through
transactions how the [__] do you think
that they came to conclusion and made
sure
that he paid the correct amount of taxes
even though he's being charged with it
by the special counsel David Weiss who
was a Who was appointed by Donald Trump
to Target Hunter Biden in Delaware by
the way talking about weaponization of
government and then the [__] stupid
gun
charges do you know how much time and
energy Hunter Biden has had to sit down
with his attorneys and go line by line
document by document [__] by bull
[__] here Hunter Biden knows this
story front back sideways up and
down and he's looked at all the evidence
I mean yeah you know he he did all this
stuff right he made these transactions
he didn't pay his taxes but you know to
be honest not fair but to be honest
Hunter Biden had a lot of he was doing a
lot of
drugs the guy had a lot of issues during
those years
and honestly should we should should we
as a country attack a private citizen no
matter who it is just because they have
a [__] mental health problem and
they're trying to self-medicate with
drugs and sex booze and
money and they make a few [__]
mistakes right should we should we
really should we really [__] should
we spend our tax dollars not only
Prosecuting that person but [__]
incarcerating that person should we
because because they got mental health
issues that're that they were dealing
with and they were trying to
self-medicate because you know in all
honesty I don't know Hunter Biden
personally but to me that's kind of
that's kind of what my conclusion of the
whole situation
is is doing drugs fun yeah is [__] a
bunch of hookers fun
probably is running around the world
staying in highclass hotels spending a
lot of money fun that probably sounds
like a lot of
fun and it was all fun to self-medicate
the problems that Hunter Biden was
having and here we are in this situation
where the Republicans are absolutely
going to [__] stick their feet in
their mouths all the way down their
throats on this issue because they're
coming after Joe Biden because the only
way they can get to
him the only way they can get to
him is through
Hunter the kid who lost his entire
family when he was a little boy in a car
accident I don't know if you know that
the one person in his life that he was
closest to his [__] brother died at a
very young
age I don't know if you know
that his dad's been in politics public
the public eye his entire life
scrutinized and then he got thrown in a
mix because his dad decided to run for
president to save our country from a big
fat fascist orange piece of menacing
[__] he did our country a
service and Joe Biden did way more than
the [__] bare minimum here Joe Biden
could have been could have just got
elected and just did what everyone
wanted him to do to appease
them because the reason why most people
voted for Joe Biden wasn't for Joe
Biden just like next year most people
who go vote for Joe Biden aren't going
to be enthusiastic about Joe Biden folks
that's the [__] truth but they're
going to vote for Joe Biden because they
don't want [__] Trump they're sick
and tired of that [__]
and they're sick and tired of the stupid
[__] that we got to sit through this
nonsense that you're going to drag the
president's son into a Committee hearing
and so it's such a bunch of [__]
that now the son is willing to just go
sit before you in public and now you're
not even willing to do that so you're
showing all your [__] cards about how
much [__] it is think about this
think about this we got [__] kids
that can't that can't get enough food
and schools they want to undo our public
education system they want to take away
your [__] health care that's right
Trump is talking about taking away your
[__] right to decent [__] Health
Care they don't want you to have a
decent [__] wage they don't give a
[__] about
that hell they don't even talk about the
deficit
anymore because they love running up the
deficit giving rich people tax
cuts
they [__] hate you they [__] hate
America and they definitely hate the
people who are here they just see them
as
pawns and the best pawns they got are
the dumbest pawns that they gather up
their [__] cult their
sheep these Trump humping [__]
idiots but I'm going to give you some
optimism here because what I'm seeing on
the internet oh my God you should see it
you should see
it they're ripping theirselves apart at
the
seams ripping themselves at the seams
it's happening right before your
eyes you may not see
it you may not want to see it but it's
happening the Republican party is
breaking the crack is real and we have
to drive that wedge down into that crack
and we have to keep driving them apart
and driving them apart and driv ding
them apart I'm telling you this Hunter
Biden
thing if there's one thing I can say
about Hunter
Biden this public testimony that he's
going to give is going to be the best
service that he's ever done this country
because what it will show is not only do
Republicans not know how to govern they
don't know how to politic anymore
they're [__] horrible at it and the
reason why they're horrible at it is
because they can't can't stop chasing
lies they can't stop their entire
[__] personalities are built on lies
why do you think it's so hard for them
to get rid of George Santos and
Democrats shouldn't let them I know I
know I know a lot of people like George
Santos needs to go blah blah blah blah
blah blah no he does not [__] let him
stay there hang yord Santos around these
Lon ass [__] neck because he is
the embodiment of Republicans and he's
the embodiment of house Republicans
because that's all they [__] do is
lie and they do it for their own power
which is exactly what George Santos is
doing just to have that one vote in
Congress well [__] me
running here we
go I'm glad you're joining me I'm
feeling much better today I actually am
you notice I haven't coughed once and I
shouldn't knock on knock
rat's back too if you didn't notice the
sound effects good morning rat good
morning rat rat is back joining us how
are you this
morning yeah no nice C nice outfit you
must have been uh in the in the mind
somewhere so rat's back with us the
cough is gone maybe maybe we'll see
we'll see we'll see but we're going to
get to the bottom of this stuff and I am
excited to have you here every single
Monday through Friday no Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube twitch and
sometimes Facebook I promise I'm trying
to figure that out Facebook is a [__]
have we ever tried to find anything on
Facebook like where there is so much
[__] it is so goddamn
clunky there's so much [__] I don't even
know where to find that they banned me
to be quite honest I can't find it I
have no idea where it where I banned how
do I how do I appeal I don't
know I'm still looking for it that's
right
as you should be looking at the Tony
michaels.com that's right go to the Tony
michaels.com hit subscribe up at the top
the current episode is always right here
at the very top see current episode link
but I want you to visit the merch store
here's the tattoo merch collection and
the my dog hates Ted collection let me
give you some some photos of that here's
the this machine kills fascism tattoo
merch collection the Tony Michaels
podcast that's right I'm going to get a
microphone tattoo my arm that says this
machine kills
fascist I'm going to get that on my arm
there's this this design is inspired by
that design I'm going to do that in
January so we're coming up close to that
we're getting really close we're we're
only less than two months away from the
tattoo content that's right I'm gonna be
showing you guys exactly I I'll be
getting pictures videos of when I'm
getting the tattoo you guys will see it
be pretty cool I'm getting a whole
sleeve I'm going to get the Statue of
Liberty on there as well but the
microphone is the first one
um so go to the Tony michaels.com check
out the tattoo merch collection also if
your cat hate hates Ted cers you might
want to get him a coffee mug even my cat
hates Ted Cruz or my dog hates Ted Cru
you can get hoodies and t-shirts there
as well as it is getting cold cold cold
Baby It's Cold
Outside that's right Christmas is coming
December is coming and we're going to do
Christmas karaoke December 17th December
17th we're have Christmas karaoke on
Sunday Sunday Sunday December 17th so
put that in your calendar while you put
that in your calendar take a break I'm
going to take a break don't go anywhere
be right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
you do if there is a trump supporter
right in front of you crying in pain
because they have to live under
communist tyranny we know what you would
do you'd reach out and give that true
American a hand now here's your chance
for only $50 a day you can help us help
those true Americans recover from
Biden's socialist reign of terror these
are those Trump supporters and this is
that moment send your donation via V to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only $50 a day recurring and it means
you'll get these Trump supporters the
critical help they so desperately need
to survive under this false regime
please donate now because those Trump
supporters you just saw can't wait
another
moment [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
them [__] them [__] them we're back to
the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
cast
oh
boy I got some um images of Hunter Biden
testifying that's right I've already got
images of Hunter Biden
testifying before the rake [__]
committees here's hun Biden yes this is
my huge Hong he's testifying there
before the committee
about how huge his hog is what do you
think do you think do you think Hunter I
mean I I'm telling you I'm telling you
man it's gonna happen think about it
we're gonna be you're gonna be watching
this live if if you're not watching it
live you're not doing it right there is
gonna be a
chance that Republicans hold up a
picture of Hunter Biden's cop
in the committee right in public open
open public and go is this your dick I
mean I've been looking at this picture
for years and I love this is my favorite
picture of your [__] I just want to
confirm here in front of everyone in
front of the world is this your
dick I don't get to make this stuff
up it's them that are making this stuff
up
what do you want from me I didn't put
them in this situation to do
[Music]
this I didn't put them in the situation
to do
this and Greg says I hope it is live oh
yeah it'll be live oh yeah public
testimonies live now my guess is they're
NE go negotiate um a private deposition
and a public
testimony that's what
Republicans clearly are headed down that
the road that they're headed down is
that they want the private deposition
because they want the the ability to you
know
like manipulate the
transcript so that way they can half
release it and I mean you know it's
going to
be it's G it's going to be where
um the truth will come out in the public
hearings and they're going to make be
made fools of
so gotta get that one out um here's
another image that we have [__] you pay
me [__] you pay
me I'm not sure what this is
um this is about [__] you pay me
but must been something I
said you know what it's
Wednesday I'm feeling a little
better I'm feeling great
today compared to yesterday I wasn't
feeling that
good
um but let's do this let's shoot the
[__] you guys like to shoot the [__] so
let's shoot the [__] let's shoot the
[__] pepp brings up a good point here
Hunter Biden's lawsuit so Hunter's
lawsuit is going to show a lot of stuff
in
Discovery um because it's a civil
lawsuit so almost all that Discovery
will come to light and really the
discovery is with Rudy Giuliani if you
guys aren't
aware if you guys aren't aware Rudy
Giuliani actually um according to Leb
Parnes now his associate that actually
went to prison for him
Le Parnes claims that Rudy Giuliani and
Le Parnes went
overseas and they had someone buy Hunter
Biden blowing hookers so that they could
distract him to steal his laptop to make
a copy of his hard drive and then
somehow that hard drive ended up in a
some obscure
[__] computer store in Delaware where
Rudy Giuliani just happened to know that
it was this is really stupid
Rudy Giuliani was directed to go steal
that
laptop I mean according to Le pares
that's what I can derive from it and
he's gonna have to go through uh many
depositions and many points of Discovery
here uh in this now that's a long
process though right we we we witnessed
as um the Trump Civil Trial in New York
against Trump organization how long that
process is in the Civil Trial to sue
someone EEG Carrol same way I mean that
process took years and years and years
and
years that's why I think Hunter Biden
now is like nope I'll go in
public because with that lawsuit because
that's the one reason why I think Hunter
Biden never actually was GNA bring a
defamation lawsuit until it was just
untenable and it was obvious defamation
Rudy Giuliani and
others were defaming Hunter Biden so I
think I think Hunter came to the
conclusion to sue now this should have
terrified Republicans I know it
terrified Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump
and the reason
why it should U oh yes I'm sorry James
is right it's Book Sales [__] you pay me
yeah with the uh with Liz Cheney you're
right all right back to Hunter Biden in
soon
so I must not be feeling 100% I must not
be feeling 100% but here's the thing
with um Hunter Biden's lawsuit it should
have terrified the [__] out of the
Republicans in the house
committees and the reason why is because
there is a certain amount of discovery
that is going to happen on Hunter
Biden's side for that civil
lawsuit a certain amount of uh uh and
and it's going to be embarrassing it's
not going to be you
know Discovery and and testimony and and
stuff that Hunter Biden really wants out
there in
public but it's kind of a you know I
Gotta Give a Little to get a little type
thing right Tit for
Tat and I think it should have terrified
Republicans and let them know and I
think even when this lawsuit came about
100 Biden finally sued I said yes this
is it this is the flood this is the
floodgates opening Hunter Biden doesn't
give a [__] anymore all this stuff is
out in public it's out in the open
because you remember they published
Hunter Biden's laptop on the
internet which most of it wasn't even
real
anyways we know that we know that hard
drive and the [__] that they're
saying wasn't
real but they put it out on the internet
so there wasn't there wasn't much that
Hunter Biden could lose by filing that
lawsuit and really there's not much he
can lose by going into open public in
Congress at this point he can only gain
at this point gain
ground and and and where it really
matters where it really matters in in
the election process is that Republicans
look like a bunch of
dummies because remember this was the
key issue in 2022 you needed to elect
house Republic an so that they could
make sure to expose Hunter Biden's [__]
to the nation you remember this this was
the hunter Biden's laptop laptop laptop
laptop laptop laptop laptop laptop
laptop
laptop I saw it in my comments all the
[__] time I would tweet something
that had nothing to do with Hunter Biden
nothing to do with Joe Biden nothing not
a goddamn thing and some [__] troll
would be like yeah but what about the
laptop right that's weird you're
obsessed with the laptop with Hunter
Biden dickpics on it it's really [__]
strange friend but okay you do
you that's where we're at if you got a
question get it in the comment section
now get it in the comment section now
what do you guys think about this uh
Trump trump was hungry Trump couldn't
eat are you [__] kidding
me is this not the dumb you know I
railed yesterday on Jonathan Carl I've
been railing on people selling books I
railed on Rachel matto for having Liz
chaining her first Prime Time interview
to pimp her book and here's the [__] you
pay me [__] you pay me [__] you pay me
book but the first thing we hear from
this
book The First first thing we hear from
book is that Kevin McCarthy told Liz
Cheney that he went down to marago to
console Trump because he was depressed
and not
eating um I don't I actually don't
believe that Kevin McCarthy said this
[__] I think Liz Jan is a [__] liar
that's that's right I'm tell I'm saying
she she's a [__]
liar maybe some degree of this right
because I mean I guess she's liable as
she lies in the
book and maybe we'll find out maybe
Kevin will
sewer but either way it's a [__] lie
either Liz Cheney is lying or Kevin
McCarthy is lying there's no [__] way
you can convince me that Trump wasn't
eating have you ever seen this fat
[__] he's never missed a fifth meal in
his life the guy eats five or six times
a day he has to right he's all hopped up
on Aderall all [__] long
right I mean the guy could afford to
skip a few meals couldn't he I mean he
could afford a couple years worth of
meals
probably no [__] way this guy was
wasn't eating come on man are you
kidding
me get the [__] out of here that's the
dumbest [__] I've ever heard in my life
like I've heard some wild
[__] wild stuff like George Santos type
wild lies right you know what I'm
talking about well you know George
Santos is there's going to be an
expulsion vote I think tomorrow is that
when they got it scheduled is tomorrow
is when George Santos will go through
his third expulsion vote this is so
stupid I actually think they should stop
that
[__] it's really
dumb it it's really dumb it only it only
it
honestly
it doesn't do anything for anyone to
have the
liar George Santos in the news for
another expulsion
vote and really it kind of
shows how how inept Congress is and I'm
not just talking about Republicans I'm
talking about Democrats here too now I
am actually more um inclined to think
that this expulsion vote is going to go
through because Democrats this is the
third time and Democrats have actually
brought this motion to the floor but I
mean Jesus [__]
Christ who who he's a republican he's no
different than the rest of them I mean
if you expel George Santos don't you
have to expel every single Republican at
this
point I mean and you have to get rid of
all the [__] Republican uh appointed
Supreme Court
justices you have to get rid of the
majority of Republican
Senators right if this if George Santos
is the standard don't we have to expel
all
Republicans I mean George Santos is no
different than any other Republican he
just tells all the Republican
lies right most Republicans pick out
like three four 12 20 lines that they
really like right they pick out a couple
dozen lies that they really like and
they tell those Lies over and over and
over again George Santos just loves
every single one of them all of them
he's like oh yeah I like that line and
that line and that line that line that
line that line that line that line that
line that line and he just tells them
all right tells all the lies I bet even
George Santos is like man that whole
that whole Trump isn't eating thing
that's a great lie that's I'm the king
of lies and that's the best lie I've
ever hold I bet I bet George Santos is
impressed impressed by the lie in Liz
Cheney's new
book [__] you pay me I think that's the
the what the book is called Liz Cheney's
new book is [__] you pay
me isn't it I don't know maybe not maybe
I'm off my rocker a lot of people don't
like that I attack Liz Shan either uh
oh the people are upset Tony that you
attack Liz you attack Liz chenie well
she's a piece of
[__] she's a woman hating piece of trash
why wouldn't you think I would attack
her she's against women's Liberties
she's a she's against women's rights
she's against women's rights to
reproductive care she wants to ban and
criminalize health
care and you think I'm gonna I'm gonna
stand in support a Liz Cheney [__] you I
will
never
never never act like some fascist is
good because they suit my needs today I
mean I'm not going to stand in Liz
Cheney's way when she's destroying
Republicans just like I'm not gonna
stand in [__] Kim bucks way when he's
destroying Republicans fine whatever
whatever you want to do Mitt Romney have
had it [__] smash them up with a
goddamn hammer do do
it do
it but if you think I'm going to stand
back and be like yeah Liz Cheney is a
hero she saved our democracy no we saved
our democracy we saved it we did the
people we got off our ass and we went
and voted against fascism we voted
against that [__] orange
slob we voted to make sure that
Republicans did not have Reign Over our
government in the executive branch we'd
had enough of that
[__] and I still think we've had enough
of that
[__] so no I'm not gonna stand and
support a fascist like Liz Cheney U I
want to show you how I welcome
descend this is important a lot of
people you know they get all snowflakey
and [__] and they don't you know they
don't like people you
know having opposite opinions of them
Dan here on YouTube says Liz Chene is
not a fascist please Dan I respect your
opinion um but just go look at Liz
Cheney's history go look at her policies
positions go look at her votes in
Congress and then tell me she's not a
fascist like I get what you're saying
and I get why a lot of people like L
Janie's a hero she was in the January 6
select hearings I cover the January 6th
s hearings from front to back the entire
thing I watched them all
live all of them I covered them I
actually produced them for midest Dutch
I don't know if you remember
that it was me behind the scenes doing
all
that when that was
happening I brought on the guests to
talk about it but Liz Cheney is no hero
because she did the bare minimum and
told the truth come on I mean
if telling the truth about Trump losing
makes her not a
fascist I don't know about that but I
appreciate Dan being here and I
appreciate Dan putting his descent in
the
comments because I think descent is good
I welcome descent especially a descent
like Dan's got here this he's not being
bigoted he's not attacking people in the
chat he's just saying his opinion
his opinion is different than mine and
that's okay that's okay if we have
different
opinions we can do that oh let's see
what else do we got here do you guys
have any um more
um foggy Ozark says [__] a Tony
[__] a I think you're saying [__]
a because I welcomed us in a lot of
people don't like when I attack Glenn
Kushner that's that's what I'm going to
do when when Glenn says stuff that's
smart and good and I agree with I'm I'll
say yay yay Glenn Glenn said something
smart and good yay but when he says
something really stupid I'm gonna point
it out too especially when it hurts our
democracy I'm gonna do
that it's gonna
happen and again I know a lot of people
aren't here for me to just make them
feel good
right A lot of people think that they're
here for me to say the things they want
to hear
I'm I'm not a [__] I'm not a
puppet
right I'm here to tell you the real all
truth that's what it says in the
beginning and I'm independent like I
don't have anybody telling me what the
[__] to do there ain't no one saying
Tony you can't say
that oh we wish you wouldn't say that
Tony because x y and z boy if you would
really refrain from saying that that
would be
great I think we're going to pull our
adver iing because you keep saying this
I don't have anyone there's no one
there's no
one there's no one telling me what to
say or what not to
say uh Dan's
infotainment yeah if that's how you want
to look at it Dan
sure I'm here to I'm here to give you
the information that you need to have
the real information that you need to
have not the [__] information right
and I'm here to point out the [__]
information that's distracting
you like what people would tweet at me
they're like hey Tony did you see this
motion from Trump's court case I'm like
I don't give a
[__] that ain't that motion that one
motion this blit that blip this week
ain't G to make a hella beans worth of
difference in our narrative folks that's
one thing Democrats and Liberals are
suck
at if you want to know the honest truth
they [__] they're horrible at this
they never they they always focus in on
these little things these little shiny
objects and they never have an arcing
[__]
narrative if you go watch right-wing
talk radio if you watch it and I know
it's difficult for some people to watch
that [__] because it is trash but if you
watch Fox News if you watch o Newsmax
Glenn Beck Sean hanity show Rush when
that [__] scumbag was
alive they'd always have a 50,000 foot
narrative and what that narrative that
50,000 foot narrative did is is capture
people's attention it's what it
did it's what it
did and when they capture their
attention then they would do the part
that has really put our country in a
tough spot they would start to brainwash
these [__] right and they start
to brainwash them with lies and
misinformation and that sort of [__]
propaganda it's propagating is what it
is you get people listen you get them to
pay attention and then you
propagate pretty simple it's media
101 the media tries to do it to you
every [__] day when they feed you
full of a bunch of [__] [__]
polls or trying to stoke Fe they're
MSNBC can't shut the [__] up they can't
shut the [__] up about Gaza oh my God
every [__] thing is Gaza Gaza Gaza
Gaz Gaza Gaz
Gaza that's one way you can tell that I
don't watch that [__]
trash MSNBC CNN or any of it that's one
way you can tell I don't watch that
[__] trash because that's all [__]
distraction that's right it's all
distraction because they don't have a
good
narrative about what's going on right
now in the country because they're not
[__] brave
enough they're cowards in the media
they're cowards they're [__]
cowards all of them Joe Scarboro up and
down ladder all of
them I pointed out to you the other day
how Min Assan is even a coward talking
about on his Twitter account how the
Muslims that he's encountered at his
Thanksgiving aren't going to never ever
ever vote for Joe Biden ever again how
cowardly are
you the guy's got God knows how many
followers on social
media right and he goes and says [__]
like that and I I like he's one of the
good ones he's one of the good ones over
there he's one of the ones that will
[__] just bury someone in truth
bombs and he says [__] like that when he
knows full well Min Assan knows full
well full well that emotions are high
and that and that because the media keep
stoking this [__] they keep covering
over and over and over again oh my God
if you're not [__] sick and tired of
hearing this
[__] and it's the whole reason I'm gonna
show you a clip today I got a clip today
of these [__] scumbags in this
country acting like they're [__]
liberals you're not [__] liberals
when when you're calling when you're not
when you can't call Hamas a [__]
terrorist
organization okay you're not a [__]
liberal you're not for the truth okay
you're just not it doesn't take many
brain cells to figure out what happened
in Israel on October 7th it doesn't take
much it doesn't take a lot
right but these people oh man they
believe the Hamas propaganda cuz the
interweb says oh the interwebs told me
[__] out of
here I don't remember what city council
meeting this is
at I'll show it to you
though it's [__] disgusting as
[__] that people who claim to be
leftists who claim to be
Liberals are pimping for a Theocratic
fascist terrorist organization get the
[__] out of
here no [__] way you don't know what
liberal or left means you have no clue
what fascism is you don't know what
theocracy is you have no idea about
ideology that's what I keep trying to
pound into people's
brains is until we really figure out in
this country what the difference between
ideology and parties
are we're going to have this mess over
and over and over again where Democrats
like oh man they're not going going to
vote for Joe Biden because of this thing
right here look Joe Biden needs to not
be old he needs not be old he needs to
say this he needs to not say that he
needs to put these shoes on instead of
those
shoes Democrats suck at this okay they
suck at messaging they suck at narrative
and they suck at it and they also suck
at just looking at looking at people who
aren't part of their [__] Coalition
because these people who are pro Hamas
and I ain't [__] you these people
who are pro Palestine are becoming Pro
Hamas like they're getting more and more
radical I went on and on and on about
how these people held up Osama Bin Laden
as their [__] hero get the [__] out
of
here they were reading letters from that
terrorist piece of
[__] they're Theocratic fascist
dummies I will never I will never ever
ever I don't care where they're at in
the world I don't care who the [__] they
are I don't care what letter they wrote
where they published it I don't give a
[__] how many people they have killed I
don't give a
[__] a fascist is a fascist is a fascist
period
period and I'll call it out every
[__] time
every single [__] time I'll call it
out rather at some [__]
bonehead at a goddamn city council
meeting or or a a a Schoolboard meeting
trying to ban books or some [__]
idiot standing up saying they support
Hamas [__] you [__]
you I don't give a [__] what
theocracy you think
that that you can support that isn't
fascism but let me tell you something
when your theocracy bleeds into your
ideology it's
fascism that's what happens I mean here
here let let me let me show you this
let's see here here you go speaking of
Theocratic
fascist here's the wiener of the house
micro of the house M
[Music]
Johnson here's Mike Johnson the wiener
of the house this morning talking about
Hunter Biden's [__] the official act
that was corrupt that Republicans are
alleging today was that when he was Vice
President Joe Biden pushed for the fire
of a Ukrainian prosecutor and this was
the subject of the impeachment of of
Donald Trump and you had a lot of State
Department officials who came in and
said this wasn't Joe Biden's policy this
was our policy he didn't do this to
benefit his son he did this because we
wanted him to do it so do they all
commit perjury uh or are you going to
bring them back for more interviews why
why are Republicans just ignoring all
that testimony no no one's ignoring
testimony let me tell you the top four
pieces of evidence with the no one's
ignoring testimony I mean I'm gonna
ignore the testimony that you're talking
about in this moment currently right
here I'm going to ignore the facts I'm
gonna ignore the truth
because that's what Theocratic fascists
do they have to ignore the truth just
like micro Johnson ignored the truth
here in that clip where the reporter is
clearly pointing out hey there is there
is testimony that has been given before
Congress about the issue of the
prosecutor in Ukraine that the United
States sent Joe Biden to make sure that
they would get rid of that [__]
because he wasn't Prosecuting crime that
bisma was
committing they
weren't Prosecuting crimes that's why
they wanted to get rid of them and the
Theocratic fascist the white Christian
nationalist he doesn't like facts he
doesn't like the truth so he's not going
to ignore that but he's gonna ignore it
well they won't be able to ignore uh
Hunter Biden in testimony when he
actually proves that the dick picks on
the lamptop are true this is what it'll
look like I think the physical evidence
of Hunter Biden's
[__] that's what they really that's what
Michael Johnson really wants that's what
the this what James comr really
wants I think I mean don't you I mean I
think there's a lot of things hiding in
Mike Johnson and James Qin on Comer's
closet
probably H well you don't believe me ah
let me show you this clip and these
people um I forget what city council
meeting it's in it's Oakland that's
right Oakland A lot of people were
posting this
online
unironically oh [__] they're like yeah
we love these people you're a dumb [__]
you're a dumb [__] these people these
people got their [__]
pronouns in their goddamn
bio and then they're [__] like yeah
Hamas yeah
baby Hamas we love
Hamas and then saying that that the
attack on October 7th was done by
Israel that that's all
[__] when the evidence clearly
points to that it was a moss watch this
[__] this is [__] gross but here it
is you shall not look away you shouldn't
Look Away there's not been beheadings of
babies and rapings Israel murdered their
own people on October 7th calling Hamas
a terrorist organization is ridiculous
racist and plays into genocidal
propaganda that is flooding our media
and that we should be doing everything
possible to combat calling Hamas a
terrorist organization is racist what
the [__] are you talking
about
listen I do not conflate Palestinians
with Hamas I'm smart enough I got enough
brain cells to rub together not to do
that I understand that Hamas is the
elected body that was elected in 2006
and they ceased all elections after that
one that's
fascist so there you go right there
there's your first [__] clue okay
there's your first [__] clue that in
2006 when Hamas won the election as the
governing body of Gaza they ceased all
elections there's your first clue you
[__] bonehead standing up saying
Hamas isn't a terrorist
organization this is really [__]
stupid [__] dumb stupid
[__] all the Putin's puppets out there
all the people who love Putin who are
probably [__] paid by Putin who are
probably Russian plants in this country
love Hamas oh my God they love
Hamas what says you keep going this is
[__] gross listen to this [__] I
support the right of Palestinians to
resist occupation including through
Hamas the armed wing of the unified
Palestinian resistance o yeah she she
supports Palestinians to arm Hamas and
commit atrocities and war
crimes these are the people who are
looking and going oh Israel is a bunch
of baby
killers listen you people have lost your
[__] minds you people have lost your
movement you have lost any anyone taking
you seriously about not only your pro
Palestinian stance and your protest but
the but the fact that you are against
genocide and you're against murder and
killing when you're standing up
supporting
supporting Hamas keep going as an Arab
asking with this context to condemn
Hamas is very anti-arab racist it's
anti-arab racist to condemn what this is
like saying when I condemn Maga as a
terrorist organization are the prow boys
or or or or [__] the oathkeepers is
white Christian Nationalist and they're
Nazis somehow that's me being racist
towards white people that's the dumbest
[__]
ever it's not racist for me to look at a
bunch of white Christian nationalists
who are the actual [__]
racist you [__] dumb
[__] Hamas main mission is to use
Palestinians as a cudel to [__]
commit genocide on Jewish people and the
Arab world has created a situation over
the decades and decades and decades
leading up to this point to have that as
the
situation it's [__] Insanity it's
insane this stupid [__] idiot thinks
that because I I me a white person a
white person would look at the [__]
racist white Christian nationalists the
Nazis in this goddamn country and call
them a bunch of [__] white Christian
nationalists that's that's me being
racist you are a stupid [__] you
are stupid [__] you people need
to get your [__] heads checked you're
worse than [__] MAA if you want to
know the goddamn
truth you're way worse than [__]
manga if you want to know the goddamn
truth it's Insanity it's
insanity
Hamas wants to [__] kill people
because they're
Jewish and it's racist for me to point
out that they're genocidal Theocratic
fascist terrorist oh
okay man great logic great rationale
there
dummy
anyone with a couple [__] brain cells
to rub together realizes
this realizes that me calling Hamas a
Theocratic fascist terrorist
organization does not mean I think all
people of Palestinian descent are Hamas
nor do they have to believe
Hamas get the [__] out of here with that
[__] no one no one who's smart
enough to [__] function
understands that just because you're
Palestinian doesn't mean you're Hamas or
that you support Hamas and really
honestly even the Palestinians that
support Hamas are [__] brainwashed
into supporting Hamas do you think do
you think I think all Rule people who
support Trump and maanga do do I think
all those people are are are just
[__] guilty as Sin no a lot of those
people have been [__] brainwashed by
their families their [__] churches
their [__] communities the [__]
politicians to some degree the people
who have been brainwashed are the
[__]
victims of [__] misinformation and
propaganda you stupid [__] all this
[__] can be true at the same
time but continue with your stupidness
the notion that this was a massacre of
Jews is a fabricated narrative many of
those killed on October 7th ma' your
time is up including children were
killed by the IDF an amendment
condemning Hamas is bald propaganda
meant to thank you your time is up to
hear them complain about Hamas violence
is like listening to a wife Peter
complain when his wife finally stands up
and fights back question oh my God the
logic is just [__] just the dumbest
[__] you've ever seen and listen
folks when people when people on the on
the internet on the right point out how
liberal are stupid as [__] this is what
they're talking
about this is what they're talking about
this is how the narrative of woke is
somehow bull somehow wrong because you
you want diversity you want Equity you
want
equality right in this country you want
progress you want everyone to have
Liberty and rights and the same [__]
freedoms but yet your dumbass gets up
and supports people who would [__]
murder
you every almost every single one of
these people that are standing before
supporting Hamas almost every one of
these dumb sons of [__] Hamas would
cut their [__] heads off and burn
them alive they'd be the first to do
it they'd be the first to do
it now here's the problem that is really
with this video let's let's finish it up
it's done let's finish up and I'll tell
you the problem with this video did
anyone else notice that those who oppose
this resolution are old white
supremacists there's been a lot of
atrocity propaganda raging from claims
of beheaded babies to mass rape Hamas is
not a terrorist organization just
because the US and Israel um deems it so
Hamas is a resistance organization that
is fighting for the liberation of
Palestinian people in their land they're
not fighting for the liberation of the
Palestinian people they came to power in
2006 and eliminated elections and if you
think eliminating elections is fighting
for the liberation of a people by taking
away their ability to elect their
leaders you're stupid you're stupid as
[__] and you just don't know what you're
talking about you don't know what you're
talking about now here's the problem
with this video is all the people out
there protesting and and and wanting
Palestinians to have Liberty because I
want Palestinians to be free I want them
to be free from Hamas and and the
[__] and the [__] atrocities that
the Arab world has used them as a cudle
to [__] want to commit genocide on
Jewish people I want them to have real
Liberty real [__] freedom I want the
entire Arab world to have real Liberty
and real [__] Freedom not this
[__] stupid [__] this idea that
somehow that theocracy is their way to
the light that's the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard
of and the real problem is is that
people out there like me and like most
of you who want Palestinians to to have
real Liberty and real
Freedom right they you want them to
experience that it should be their
[__] it should be their human
right to experience fre freedom and
liberty and not be oppressed by anyone
whether it be Iran Hamas any other
terrorist organization in the Arab world
or Israel for that matter if you want to
throw them in the
mix but the problem with this video the
problem with this video is it smashes
that idea when these people go out and
and and use these boneheaded [__]
propagated ideas when they believe
propaganda that has been spread to them
on Tik Tok because they watched a Tik
Tock video about the Osama Bin Laden
letters oh man it was eye opening and
now I'm GNA go get a
Quan
when they when they when they use when
they use this propaganda to do stupid
[__] like this they undermind the
ability for Palestinians to experience
Freedom or Liberty you [__]
idiots what do you think the I what do
you think the purpose of the propaganda
from Hamas and the Arab world
is what do you think it is how do you
think Isis was created you guys remember
[__] Isis don't you H you probably
don't this seems like a million years
ago doesn't
it what do you think that
was an Army built on [__]
propaganda an army of [__] Theocratic
fascist genocidal
Maniacs wanting to kill people who
weren't them because that's what
Theocratic fascists do I don't give a
[__] what religion they are for BB
Netanyahu is a [__] Theocratic
fascist
folks BB Netanyahu is a piece of
trash he commits all kinds of [__]
crimes in the West Bank illegal
occupations and
[__] and we got to sit back and act like
these two truths can't be the same at
the it can't be all the
same but let me tell you something if
you think that Gaza is going to be
liberated in the Palestinians are going
to be liberated in this effort you're
dumb as dog [__] too you're dumb as dog
[__] if you think Gaza is going to be
any better than the way Hamas left it
after Israel's done after all these
hostages are exchanged after the
ceasefire after BB Netanyahu is [__]
tossed out because he's probably gonna
be tossed out
eventually that right-wing piece of [__]
the one reason why is because Israel
doesn't like him because he's
anti-democrat ratic that's how
democracies normally handle people who
don't like democracy they toss them in
the [__]
trash just like we're gonna do next year
with Donald Trump just like we did last
year in 2022 when there was no red wave
and we won gains in the Senate just like
2020 when we [__] took took the White
House back just like just just this last
[__] couple weeks where in Ohio
Virginia and Kentucky we said [__] no to
a bunch of anti Democratic people named
Republicans this is what democracies do
folks they toss people who are
anti-democratic in the [__]
trash but if you think Gaza is going to
be in better
shape after this you're dumb you're
[__] dumb it's not gonna be it's
not it's not gonna be it's not going to
get any better it it it'll appear to be
better for a while right oh God there'll
be peace in Gaza and rebuilding of
Gaza but there isn't going to be freedom
for the Palestinians the Arab world
doesn't want that Iranians don't want it
jordanians don't want it the Egyptians
don't want it they don't want turkey
doesn't want it they do not
want Palestinians to have their freedom
what [__] excuse are they going to
use to arm terrorist organizations to
attack attack Israel what
excuse what excuse and this is the
problem when you get [__] three
different religions three different
theocracies fighting over one little
speck of land this is what you
get you get murder genocide War killings
propaganda lies terrorist genocide this
is what you get when you get a bunch of
[__] religious zealots fighting over
a speck of
land but when you you when you as
someone who say you want to free
Palestinians support the propaganda that
is designed not to free them I don't
know if you know
that but if you start believing and not
only believing but go to City Council
meetings in
Oakland and start saying that you're
you're for Hamas and Hamas is not a is
not a terrorist
organization you're really undermining
Palestinians freedom and that's exactly
what Hamas wants that's exactly what the
Theocratic fascists wants that's what
the white Christian nationalists want in
this country too they want they want a
bunch of dumb liberals to think that
they're fighting an anti-war cause by
saying Hamas isn't
terrorist well [__] me
running and honestly they lost their
movement and it's a shame because the
Palestinians I don't care if they're
here if they're refugees I don't give a
[__] if they go to another country as
refugees I don't care if they're in Gaza
or and they're in the West Bank they're
in Jordan or Egypt I don't give a [__] I
don't care where the Palestinian people
are if you're Palestinian you're a human
you deserve [__] Liberty you deserve
[__]
Freedom real [__] Freedom real
[__] Liberty from any Theocratic
fascist I don't care if it's BB
Netanyahu or
Hamas I don't give a
[__] and when you as a liberal claiming
to be a liberal you don't know anything
about
liberalism these [__] idiots in this
clip that I showed you here in Oakland
California these [__] boneheads don't
know anything about being liberal they
have no [__] clue they just don't
know they're boneheads they're
idiots they'll believe whatever the
internet machine tells them to believe
because they're anti-war who I'm
anti-war well great so why are you why
are you believing propaganda that is
intended to to create more
war really stupid [__] really stupid
[__] all right don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
best sh
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy de's Tammy by the time we reach
DC weight was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live love and blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I even seen my
cousin bro in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day you're
T
me [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast o speaking of Theocratic fascist
let me show you a white Christian anist
in this
country that is trying to press the
rights of other religions and other
people of other religions in Oklahoma
that's right the um superintendent of
schools why Ryan
Walters he's a [__]
Nazi oh full-blown Nazi oh my God like
you can't get any more Nazi in this son
of a [__] in Oklahoma now the news is
is that an Oklahoma Elementary School
let kids deliver Christian prayers over
the inacom during morning announcements
after the ffrf which uh let me let me
give you what the ffrf is is the excuse
me it's the freedom from religion
Foundation okay it's a
501c3 that supports all freedom from all
religions everywhere right the freedom
of religion isn't your freedom to
oppress or or press your religion on me
it's my choice as to what my religion is
not your choice see um but after the
ffrf warned them this was illegal which
it is it's unconstitutional to
deliver Christian prayers over the
intercom during the morning
announcements the school
stopped so when the school was warned by
this organization that hey you either
[__] you [__] around and you're gonna
find
out um predictably the state
superintendent and Christian nationalist
I would call him a white Christian
Nationalist and the Nazi but um you know
they didn't go as far here Ryan Walters
claims this is
bullying well I mean of course the Nazis
are going to whine these are Nimo nimap
poop
Nazis and there's no better example of a
nimap poop Nazi than the superintendent
of Oklahoma schools than Ryan Walters
listen to this see if you see this as a
threat today we see cig Public Schools
backing down to a radical atheist group
you know we're going to continue to
fight for religious liberty and
religious freedom here in the state of
Oklahoma what we've seen as a group
that's funded by George Soros that is
atheist that is from out of state has
come in and targeted children that are
initiating prayer in pray Public Schools
yeah see here here's the thing is that
if you allow Christian prayer in schools
what you do is you allow Muslim prayer
in schools seek prayer in schools Jewish
prayer in school you can't stop the
waterfall of prayer and the reason why
is because there's freedom of religion
so this is why the founders said you
know what it's probably better off that
we just separate ourselves State and
religion we just separate it and we just
give people the freedom to believe what
they want to believe on their own their
own personal independent beliefs
whatever you want to do if you want to
believe some stupid religion that's your
thing but I am free from believing your
stupid religion also I am free from that
inside public
spaces so which religion is it Ryan that
you want them to pray to um this is the
problem that Ryan this [__] Nazi has
is that he's a white Christian
Nationalist and he only wants white
children in
Oklahoma to pray to the white jesus okay
that's the problem that Ryan has and
this is the problem that this idiot has
about rubbing brain cells together
enough to understand what is
constitutional and what is not and why
it is constitutional and why it is
unconstitutional but again he blames
Soros in his little anti-semitic way
because he's a Nazi he's a [__] Nazi
oh I I I I almost bet if there was Nazis
standing on overpasses holling Hitler
talking about how they want prayer in
schools Ryan Walters like yeah those are
my kind of guys woohoo yeah
Ryan Walters would be all about those
Nazis well let's keep going Ryan well
you know just as bad we have prag public
schools bowing down to these bullies and
telling their students that they're not
going to allow them to initiate prayer
anymore it's outrageous we have to take
a stand for our students freedom of
religion their freedom to express their
religious beliefs no matter what those
religious beliefs may be no that's not
what you're doing that's not what you're
doing
listen students are allowed to have
religious beliefs when I was in school
there was prayer in school there's
nothing preventing anyone to pray in
school nothing not a goddamn thing not a
[__] thing when I was a when I was a
when I was in school when I was in high
school they'd have signs up all over to
school it would be it would called meet
me at the flag that's what it was it was
meet me at the flag and it was a bunch
of [__] Christian students whatever
they wanted to do they wanted to pray
but they they they put up signs and it
wasn't School sanction it was was a
group of students that got together and
prayed at the flag pole before school
every day before school started they
would go and pray the other thing
too is my school actually had a back
gorean I don't know if you guys know
what that is it's a religious ceremony
it's a religious graduation ceremony
that's right they had it in the school
they had preachers come and
pray now you aren't required to attend
right because they can't require you to
attend because you can't sanction a
religion right you can't do that you
can't do that you can't the school can't
sanction a religion because to see you
at the pole thing right now in my school
it was all white the town I grew up in
all white all Christians there were very
few people in that town that weren't
Christian I mean most of them weren't
actually Christian they just claimed to
be Christian they went to a [__]
Christian Church but most of them were
[__] bigoted Nazis right so they're
not really Christian they're not really
following the the the teachings of
Christ for crying out loud I mean let's
stop pretending acting acting like Ryan
here is a [__] actual Christian is
[__] wildly hilarious isn't it I mean
I call him a white Christian nationalist
because he's white meaning he's he's a
racist piece of [__] he's a Christian
he's claiming self-proclaim that he's a
Christian he does actually follow he
didn't follow the the F the teachings of
Christ and he's a
nationalist meaning he's a goddamn
fascist but you know whatever so what
we've got to do yeah is we've got to
tell groups like the freedom from
religion group like the acou we will
never back down to your bullying Antics
we will not allow atheism to be the
state sponsored religion oh my God he's
saying the quiet part out loud he's
saying it out loud and this is really
dumb that he'd make a video like this
because this video is going to be used
in a
court that he's actually saying when
he's saying this he's saying atheism is
the is because what he's saying is no
religion is atheism which is all
[__] the freedom of religion is is
not no religion that's nonsense I'm a
[__] atheist okay I don't believe
that there's a God I don't believe that
there's some powerful being I just think
this is all one marvelous accident
that's right now I I I don't get to
explain things in my life with wild
crazy stories from a book and and some
people you know think that it's a good
thing that you live as an atheist but in
most cases you know a lot of times you
need some Jesus you need some God you
know when you have tough times and you
have hardships it's nice to have faith
right I'm sure it is I don't have that
I'm okay with it I've come to terms with
it but I'm not and I I there was a point
in my atheist belief right if it's a
belief it's a non-belief really but
there was a point in my atheism that I
would try to get people to not believe
and I understood really quickly that
that was wrong because they would be
trying to get me to believe and I was
like this is really dumb this is really
dumb I should be able to say you can
believe what you want to believe right
you get to believe what you want to
believe even if it's wildly stupid and I
don't agree with it you get to you get
to believe it and I get to believe what
I want to believe even if I believe that
nothing exists it's okay we can both
have that same that those different
beliefs and still have commonality right
but we can't have commonality with an
[__] like this listen be so what
we've got to do is we've got to tell
groups like the freedom from religion
group like the ACLU we will never back
down to your bullying Antics we will not
allow atheism to be the state sponsored
religion of our school system not here
in Oklahoma you guys need to leave our
kids alone we will not stand for it and
we will continue to fight for religious
liberty here in the state of ok he's
gonna fight for religious liberty by
forcing students to say Christian
prayer folks if you're not seeing how
dumb this
is
right if you're not seeing how dumb this
is here here's an image of it
here's people on being forced to pray
forced to pray this way to pray
attention this is a real player not a
fake one no this is real prayer this is
a real prayer not a fake one not your
fake one that you that you
believe it's really stupid because what
what Ryan Walters is really trying to do
here is he's trying to get everyone in
Oklahoma to be Christian like him and
he's trying to oppress people's rights
to have the religion that they want to
have that's what it is and that's why
he's going to lose this battle and I
actually welcome Ryan making videos like
this and keep talking like this and keep
saying [__] like this because he's a
Nazi he's a white Christian nationalist
he's of the same ilk as the Speaker of
the House the wiener of the house mikro
Johnson I bet this guy has an online
accountability partner that he train
that he trades gay porn with excuse me
porn excuse
me I don't know that about um Ryan
Walters or not I it may have just been a
forent slip but I'm sure he has an
accountability partner that uh him and
his accountability partner trade gay
porn porn with I'm sure that's probably
a thing I'm sure he's got that Christian
app so what do you want from me again if
you're if you're in
support if you're a liberal you're like
I support Hamas I support Hamas as an
organization then you support this guy
in Oklahoma doing what he's doing to
school children by forcing them to say
Christian prayers you [__]
dummies same same [__] same
same Theocratic fascist
yes this guy isn't a militant
yet you give him another couple hundred
years of this [__] and you keep [__]
letting them erode away at our democracy
and our liberties and our
freedom they'll get there they'll be all
dressed up in [__] military costumes
running around acting like they're the
liberators of the white Christians in
this country we're the liberators of the
white Christians in this
country the [__] out of here
and you're worried and you're and
MSNBC and CNN is reporting on the
Theocratic fascists over there when
they're missing the Theocratic fascist
that eroding your Liberty here you're so
worried about the Palestinians Liberty
but you're not worried about our Liberty
here you're willing to spread Theocratic
fascist propaganda from overseas but
then you're outraged outraged when
Theocratic fascists take power
here you need to get your [__] head
on right Jess Piper speaking of schools
in this fight for schools you know Jess
Piper she's been a guest on the show
she's a good friend of mine she's a a
huge huge warrior in this fight for
schools and the right to schools but she
posted something this morning says
imagine a faith so empty that you think
bringing prayer into schools is
following Jesus
but bringing free lunches is
not oh man if we could just get Ryan
Walters if we could just get Ryan
Walters to fight so passionately to
actually give children nutrition in
schools as opposed to force them to
[__] pray wouldn't that be
great that's where I'd like to have I
mean I would be okay with with Ryan
Walters being a white CHR chrisan
Nationalist and claiming he's a
Christian he's not a [__] Christian
if he actually followed the teachings of
Christ and did what Jess said here and
actually want to feed children instead
of [__] brainwash them into his
[__]
religion [__] that
guy [__] that guy I I just want to point
that out what's going on in Oklahoma in
case you didn't see what's going on in
Oklahoma
let's see what else we got here do we
have some more uh oh yeah here's a great
rake step here's um Elise stonic this
morning speaking of white Christian
nationalist here's a stonic on um white
people America this morning on Fox
Business oh excuse me I think it's
called morning with Maria I'm sorry I
was
I'm sorry let's let's let's see what
Alise stonic has to say can you settle
this for us what is the difference
between a public hearing and a hearing
that's behind closed doors why is the
oversight committee pushing that it has
to be behind closed doors what's the
difference between a public hearing and
a private hearing can you tell our
stupid audience that doesn't know how to
think for themselves can you brainwash
them
into into thinking that it's much better
for Hunter Biden to appear in private
than in public can you do that for us
can you propagate lies for us this
morning can you please do that at Le
stonic and do it with real heavy
stupidity go
ahead well Maria exactly what you said
in an open public hearing you see the
Democrats turn this into a charade it's
five minutes on each side and it doesn't
allow you to get to the facts in a
deposed manner a closed door hearing
allows a legal definition that is the
only compliance with the Republican
subpoena it allows you to follow the
facts to ask follow-up questions and
that is incredibly important when we're
doing this investigative work in part of
this impeachment inquiry and my
colleague chairman comr is exactly
correct this is not about Hunter Biden
this is about Joe Biden and whether or
not he is compromised I believe he is
fully compromised and I believe that as
we continue uncovering evidence we will
see that this is the greatest political
corruption Scandal of our lifetime but
that can only be found if we're able to
follow the evidence in a closed door
deposition and of course we welcome an
open hearing for the American people to
see but there has to be a closed door
deposition you see that you see that
they're horrible at this politics thing
they don't know how to government they
don't know how to politics anymore
either I don't know how they didn't see
this
coming how did they see this coming
right I I don't I don't know how they
didn't see this coming that Hunter Biden
would call their [__] Bluff and make
absolute fools out of them right
I mean it's only politics
101 when you when you throw something
out there in the politics right
especially in the arena of the of a
house oversight committee especially
when you Yammer on and on and on and on
and on and on and on about it and you
run on the
issue that you're gonna impeach Joe
Biden or impeach Hunter Biden or some
[__] how didn't they see that this was
going to
happen I don't
know I mean it could be that they're
just [__]
dumb right or could it be that they
really they really know that their
followers are going to believe any
goddamn lie they tell them they really
are they're gonna believe any lie they
tell them these people are [__]
stupid folks they're brainwashed they're
delusional
qanon is a hell of a drug it really is
kon's a hell of a drug
because qanon makes them think they're
smart right when they're really [__]
stupid they're ignorant as [__] they
have no clue about how this [__] works
not a [__] clue not a clue to know
that Hunter Biden is probably going to
do a deposition and he's going to
negotiate an open hearing but how they
wouldn't know that he would call their
Bluff and the attorneys would call their
Bluff I have no idea because they look
dumb as dog [__] here and they look dumb
with their supporters but their
supporters will eat any kind of sheep
food that they feed them so listen to
this look this is a serious
investigation this is about public
corruption at the highest levels of our
government we have over 10,000 pages of
documents that we've obtained pertaining
to Hunter Biden's Financial transactions
with our enemies around the world we
need to ask him hundreds of questions if
he comes in for one hearing with 24
members having five minutes each to ask
questions with the Democrats yelling and
screaming like they do every hearing we
would probably get about 30 to 35
questions in we need to ask him hundreds
of questions about specific transactions
with our enemies around the world okay
so he keeps saying that enemies around
the world in transactions but listen to
the part about the government see if you
can catch it document that we've
obtained pertaining to Hunter Biden's
Financial transactions with our enemies
around the world we need to ask him
hundreds of questions if he comes in for
one hearing with 24 members having five
minutes each to ask questions with the
Democrats yelling and screaming like
they do every hearing we would probably
get about 30 to 35 questions in we know
about public corruption at the highest
levels of our government public
corruption at the highest levels of our
government I want to ask James comr a
followup question if I
can what part what highest part of
government was Hunter Biden a part of
can you tell me
that was Hunter Biden the vice is Hunter
Biden the president of the United
States is
he is he the president of the United
States it feels like Hunter Biden is
gonna be impeached here I'm not gonna
lie to you it really feels like Hunter
Biden's gonna be
impeached but this this is the
stupidity and this is the the rakes that
they step on because again people not
only can they not govern they can't
politic
anymore and the reason why they can't
politic is because they believe they can
get their sheep to eat any food that
they feed them like any food any food at
all let me give you a couple examples
here all right have you guys heard of
the Dunning krger times right there's a
satire um internet website out there
it's called the Dunning Krueger times
all
right
um here here's an image from the Dunning
Krueger times just the other day here
let me show you this America's last line
of defense the Dunning Krueger times now
if you see this and you don't know what
Dunning Krueger means right you're not
sure what the Dunning Krueger theory
is then you would fall for this [__]
right you would fall for it if you
didn't know what dun and kruer means
now right- Wingers fall for this [__]
all the time now if you don't know this
is gar Brooks here this is Hank Williams
Jr here now the dun and Krueger times
because it's satire meaning it's a joke
it's a gag it's a
goof has taken an image now they've made
let me tell you something this dun in
career times has made a name for
themselves I don't know how much
advertising they're selling on this
website and how much money they're
making but it's got to be mountains of
money mountains of
money and the one person and the one
piece of satire that they've made
mountains of money off of is gar Brooks
I'm not [__] you go go Google after
the show not right now not right now
godd damn it don't leave the show but
after the show go Google Dunning Krueger
gar
Brooks article after article after
article after article on the Dunning ker
times several mon months
ago uh at the CMA Fest and I talked
about this the other day um gar Brooks
put out a statement that because people
were upset that he was serving budlight
at his new bar at CMA Fest over the
summer and gar Brook said I don't give a
[__] if you don't like that I'm serving
Bud Light if you don't like it take your
bigoted ass somewhere else I don't need
your
money and that was
real months later the Dunning Krueger
times actually reported that Brooks was
booed off a stage in Texas which was not
true not true it's
satire and oh man the rightwing just
clung to this just clung to
this and they and and they're making
money off this because here's the
headline Hank Williams Jr says he
wouldn't be caught dead on stage with
gar Brooks which that may be true I
don't know how [__] Hank Williams Jr
feels about gar Brooks I have no idea I
really don't know I know Hank Williams
Jr is
probably some sort of bonehead I mean I
like his music his dad's music's good
too but I doubt that Hank Williams Jr
would say he wouldn't be caught dead on
stage with gar Brooks the biggest
[__] country music artist of all time
that's right he's the biggest country
music artist of all time I don't care if
you like him hate him love him whatever
you don't like his music that's just the
[__] fact
period it's just the
fact just how it is but these Bon hands
believe this [__] um and I pointed it
out here is um I pointed it out I said
go point and laugh at all the morons in
the comments that have no idea the dun
and crat times is satire these Bon heads
will literally fall for anything because
if you go to this post this account
called Cowboy
FL Ultra magga America First unvexed and
now deplorable listless
vessel posted a picture
of Hank Williams Jr and he posted the
headline and I mean comment after
comment after comment after comment they
bought it hook line Sinker they bought
it hookline Sinker now I told everyone
to go [__] with these people so now
there's a bunch of [__] in here about
the dun and Krueger
times because I pointed it out on
Twitter so if people like oh I'm going
to go [__] with these
people and I mean they're posting [__]
about George Strait saying this they're
posting all and that's off the dun and
Krueger times
too they'll
believe anything anything the interwebs
tell them they'll believe
it they'll believe it so it's not
surprising that they believe [__] like
Hunter Biden's going to be impeached
right it's not surprising when they
believe stuff like oh it's religious
freedom when we make you pray in school
it's that's that's our freedom to make
you pray in school right it's not not
crazy that they believe that
[__] it's not crazy that they believe
that vouchers are good school vouchers
are good let me show you this video here
I came across this video and it's a
great one explaining School vouchers in
Texas but really this is the same model
that all these [__] scumbags are
using these Republican scumbags are
using all around the country in all
these states to undermine your public
schools and your community's public
education listen to this this voucher
scam is being pitched as choice for poor
and workingclass kids but poor kids
can't get the voucher for a whole host
of reasons that we've already touched on
because they're denied admission because
there aren't enough private school seats
because they can't cover the difference
between the voucher and the tuition cost
or because the private school doesn't
provide transportation or special
education services in other states that
have tried these scams this has become a
coupon for wealthy families to save on
their private school bills New
Hampshire's voucher program has similar
prioritization as this bill do you know
what percent of their voucher program
has gone to kids already in
school no sir we don't have that data
it's 89% so 8 9% of the vouchers that
were given in New Hampshire for their
Voucher Program 89% of them were already
going to private schools this wasn't a
situation where they were taking someone
out of a shitty public school and
sending them to A Better Private School
it was just people getting their tuition
paid who do you think go to private
schools that are already paying tuition
that are receiving these vouchers who do
you think it is do you think it's poor
inent people you think it's people who
are in your community that really can't
afford transportation to get their kids
to school probably can't afford school
lunch you think it's those people that
are sending their kids to private
school oh well keep going do you know
what percentage of the recipients of
Arizona's Voucher Program were already
in practice Arizona sir 75% o ouch do
you know what percentage of the
recipients of Wisconsin's voucher
program this is not gonna go well 76%
ouch so under this bill is it true that
a wealthy CEO sending his two kids to an
elite four-year private high
school would get more than $80,000 in
taxpayer
funds uh presumably that's over some
period of time that you're referring to
so it is
possible Maran am I am I miss oh man
possibility is it
not it's a possibility well that's
enough for a new
Mercedes for that CEO at the did you
catch that
$80,000 $80,000 they're going to give a
rich person your money your [__]
money they're going to give them your
money your community's money money
that's supposed to go back into the
community into the schools into the
teachers they're gonna give that to that
[__] Rich son of a [__] that's got
the big old house on the
hill that's got plenty of money to send
his [__] kids to private school if he
wants to that's their [__] choice
they can send their kids to a public
school there's public school districts
all over this
country they choose to send them to a
private school what they're doing is
they're co-opting your [__] tax
dollars they're stealing your [__]
money they're stealing your kids public
education and the reason why they want
to do it is because they want to shut
down the schools they don't want Public
Schools they don't want people in the
lower class to get
educated they're sick of that de
Democratic idea that everyone no matter
who you are no matter where you come
from no matter how rich or poor your
parents are you should be able to
receive a decent education in this
country that undermines that whole
[__]
process to make this into a fascist
state if everyone has a leg up if every
Democratic demographic has a leg up then
what is going to happen to the white
Christian nationalist I mean they're a
bunch of dumb
[__] how will white Christian
nationalists
compete if if the Poes are educated
expense of my students on the west side
of San Antonio and students in the third
W of Houston and students in the Rio
Grand Valley students in suburbs and
small towns around the state this would
be a massive transfer of wealth from the
bottom to the top if this passed
it's
w listen to this last part let me catch
it here this last part it's wealth
distribution from the bottom to the top
but what is it the Top If this passes
it's welfare for the wealthy it's
welfare for the
wealthy it's what it is it's welfare for
the
wealthy and if you're not seeing that
then you're not seeing it clearly and if
you're not speaking out against this
[__] in your communities then you're not
doing it correctly I don't care if
you're kids still go or don't go or your
tax dollars if you're a property owner
okay this is how Most states do it not
all states but this how Most states do
it most public education is funded by
tax dollars and it's funded by property
tax
dollars so they get the federal money
they get the tax dollars in the state
and the state decides how they're going
to fund the
schools it's how they do
it and then once the school gets the
funding then the the school board the
elected School Board figures out how
they use that funding within the legal
parameters I don't know if you know
that's how our governments work and how
our government surrounding our public
education works but that's that's
essentially how it
works so if you pay on your property tax
if you're a property owner and you pay
property tax to that school you're
actually paying it to rich people now
you're giving your [__] money your
[__] money to rich
people the same people that are pay and
they get to keep their property tax by
God [__] yeah man they get to keep their
property tax 80% of them that are
already sending their kids to public
school private schools and not Public
Schools who pay property tax now they
get to get their money
back in a voucher
scheme it's welfare for the wealthy is
what it is and [__] that [__]
[__] that
[__] oh oh what wait do I hear mining do
I hear mining I I think I think we're
GNA finish on a great story here rat's
back with us today rant this is the
story this is the story that you wanted
me to cover today right the minor is
that why you're dressed like a minor
today yeah okay all right all right so
we got one more story that we're going
to cover here um and I'm going to check
and see while I'm doing this um if Gabe
Sanchez has a show today I'm pretty sure
he does but I haven't heard from him yet
so we're gonna go to this story um Al
jazer has it here on Twitter it's about
rat miners I'm get rat is that why this
story is so near and dear to you because
it's a bunch of rat miners
yes so rat miners rescued workers
trapped under collapsed tunnel in
India's himalayans
after 1777
days 17
days they got these miners can you
imagine being
traed for 17 days but rat I'm happy that
it was rat
miners that got this what a great story
yeah see it's that maybe is that where
you were at yesterday is that where you
were I mean we know a lot of people
pointed
oh you were sick I was sick too when I
was here you oh so I have to show up but
you didn't oh well yeah okay all right
all right I get it I get
it everyone knows that we have the rat
in the background in a laboratory but
you didn't know that he was helping
people tunneling thanks for the story I
really appreciate it's it's a great
story and that the rap miners rescued
workers trapped under the collapsed
tunnel after 17 days
that's a great story
heartfelt
story there to kind of end on I'm
waiting to see if Gabe Sanchez is gonna
join us and if he's gonna have a shield
I haven't I haven't heard from him
yet where are you where are you dud
Where's My Car Dude where's my
car I don't know if Gabe got a car yet
or not does anyone know have he got a
card yet or not does anyone know I don't
know maybe has maybe hasn't oh let's see
we got a few more minutes while we're
waiting on Gabe Sanchez let me see if I
can find um another story
here um actually I had a video from Jess
Piper maybe we'll play that nope NOP I
do have one oh boy this will warm your
hearts this will show
you oh what I'm talking about when I say
these white Christian nationalist are
snowflakes you guys know Tim pool oh God
if you haven't heard of Tim
pool maybe you don't want to hear about
timpool but this is I don't know who
this guy is he's on Tim timcast Tim
pool's podcast let's see what is his
name his name is j Jeremy Jeremy boring
I'm not kidding you his name is Jeremy
boring I know this guy is he's
definitely a
racist definitely
misogynist but listen to what he says
here listen to him whin and complain
about he how he doesn't get to call
black people the n-word with a hard arm
listen to
this here's the
problem the problem is that anonymity on
the internet allows for the
ghettoizing of beliefs that are not
approved by the regime the regime so a
lot of people will say well I have to be
I have to be anonymous on the internet
because my boss finds out that I've got
these views they'll fire me but you're
only in the position where your boss
could fire you for finding out about
those views because you've allowed those
views to be completely ghettoised
through anonimity online if uh I
if five million people came out today
and said uh the
nword oh my God okay I don't know if you
see where this is going rant you see
where this is
going you might want to dig another
tunnel um so what this guy is about to
say is that if we just get enough people
online and I don't know if this guy's
been on Twitter lately or not but if we
just get enough people online to call
black people the n-word we'll be much
better off we won't need
anonymity listen to this listen to this
[__] I'm not recommending it but no one
would ever get fired for saying the
nword
again to you wouldn't be able to you
would have brought that to you would
have brought that to a conclusion that
little um my my
God these whiny little [__] right
okay I am not
opposed I am not opposed red to someone
going on their social media
account and possibly breaking terms of
service on their social media account
some websites it's not actually breaking
terms of service so I'm not opposed to
someone going on Twitter and telling us
who they are right I'm not a place with
that I'm
not I would much rather know who someone
is than this [__] where they they
they hide in the shadows and they hide
their racism in the shadows and their
bigotry in the
shadows much rather just know who they
are I would much rather just post it out
on the internet whether it breaks the
terms of services or not what these
little [__] are whining about is that
they don't get to be racist without
consequence what the [__] are you listen
folks freedom of speech no matter what
the speech no matter what you say where
you say it how you say it in public okay
freedom of speech is not freedom of
consequence speech and consequences now
we have Gabe Sanchez with
us I don't know how are you are you late
today is that what this is uh I'm late
but I'm I got my show in two minutes are
you are you looking at are you watching
a clip of Jeremy boring yeah boring he's
boring as [__] oh man he's talking about
he's whining about how he doesn't get to
anonymously call black people in wordss
with the hard R are you gonna watch this
clip at your show I'll watch it no
um here here yeah let's let's watch a
little bit here and then I'll I'll
little absurdity in our
culture if uh
if five million people came out today
and said uh the
nword I'm not recommending it but no one
would ever get fired for saying the NW
again to you wouldn't be able to you
would have brought that to you would
have brought that to a conclusion that
little absurdity in our culture
absurdity uh would be brought to an end
the ghettoizing of our beliefs allows
for the punishment of anyone who steps
outside of the ghetto yeah so if they
catch you saying what you believe they
can fire you yep but if we all just had
our names on and we're saying the things
that we believe and you might say
that we would have more cultural
cohesion if we didn't have online
anonymity too because the online
anonymity also allows us to become more
radicalized in ways that Pro left and
right in ways that probably aren't
ultimately good so I I [__] moan
hands man but here's the here's the
thing he made a he made a point there at
the end always they always they always
slap head first into he's like oh if we
don't anonymize people then we wouldn't
have this radicalization oh yeah totally
what he's saying though is is I want to
not have I want to be able to say this
as I want to be able to be racist as
myself right right exactly not have I
want freedom of speech with freedom from
consequences is what they really I want
to be a bigot without having social
societal uh workplace ramifications yeah
any anything I don't want to have a fist
hit my face because I said this word
that I really want to say in
I want to be able to whatever I want to
say without consequence and here's the
consequence you got to get your ass over
to your show that's a Cons with I know I
know I gotta go I gotta go get the hell
out get the hell out of here rat thank
you for the story Gabe Sanchez thank you
for joining us and stick around if
you're on YouTube or if you're on Twitch
which is the only place you're watching
me right now because I'm still banned
from Facebook but if you're on YouTube
and twitch don't go anywhere you're
gonna you're going to get cut to Gabe
Sanchez right after this if you're on
YouTube or twitch don't go anywhere what
was that live what was that live is
right up right after the show here uh
let's see if I can get
this get this thing going here there it
is all right now now we're good to go
we're good to go same time same place
tomorrow Gabe Sanchez what was that live
right now right now don't go anywhere
surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
in political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow Tony
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's muor head ass
speaking